So, Leute, bin ich am Start.
Ja, ich hab Gott auf der Platte.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum.
Hast du mal Bronze-Own gespielt?
Was sagst du dazu?
Ah, es ist voller Cheaters wieder.
Okay, nice.
Das hört sich an, ich weiß, dass es ein Mario-Kart-Soundtrack ist,
aber das hört sich an von der Musik her wie ein Mario-Soundtrack von Helene Fischer.
So Schlagermäßig, stampf, stampf, oder?
Passt überhaupt nicht.
Jetzt kommen sie aber alle hier.
Den haben wir noch am Start hier.
Der Akte ist am Start, der Yannick ist am Start,
der Tribulon, der Eax, der Eichler,
Bassfanation, kann ich auch sprechen,
Herz93,
Lickybrain,
E4T,
Max ist auch am Start,
Kusswart ist auch da,
Nea,
Coding Niklas,
jetzt kommen sie alle am Start hier.
Das ist ein Hex-Wars, sehe ich von den Namen her schon.
So.
Jaja.
Wir sind ziemlich pünktlich, weil es ist genau 10.
Es ist genau 10.
Der Sando ist auch am Start, XD, XD, XD, XD, ist auch da.
Ups, falsche, falsche.
Ich wollte steht posten.
Also,
ähm,
was wollte ich denn sagen?
Irgendwas wollte ich erzählen am Anfang.
Hab ich vergessen.
War nicht so wichtig.
Ich wollte auch mal ein Tablet gucken, vielleicht fällt es mir da wieder ein.
Pünktlicher Stream, ja, ultra, ultra.
Hyper, hyper pünktlich.
Boah, Gott.
Ähm,
was wollte ich denn erzählen?
Hm.
Ich weiß nicht.
Äh, wusstet ihr,
ich weiß nicht, ob etwas anderes einfällt,
wusstet ihr, dass die Amis jetzt ein Gesetz haben oder machen wollen?
Nein.
Ich habe gelesen, dass alle Geräte ein sinnvolles, sicheres Default-Passwort haben müssen.
Habe ich mir auch gedacht, dass, ja, Wahnsinn, dass da mal einer auf die Idee kommt.
Pünktlicher als die Pan, das stimmt.
Das ist ja aber auch keine große Kunst, ne.
Ja, und kaum ist das jetzt, äh, im Gespräch, dass alle Geräte ein sinnvolles Default-Passwort haben müssen,
laufen schon die ersten Leute wie der Amok dagegen und sagen, nein, das dürft ihr auf gar keinen Fall machen, weil dann ist das einricht-,
von Servern viel, viel schwieriger, wenn ich da auf einmal 50 Server einrichten muss.
Das ist auch nicht, was die alle für Probleme haben immer.
Man kann auch alles, alles immer, immer schlecht finden.
Ich finde das gut, wenn die Geräte alle mit einem ordentlichen, ähm,
Default-Passwort kommen.
This Battle Royale Game is officially a bad, ist, ist das, ist das Firestorm?
Ne, das ist kein Firestorm.
Doch, das ist Firestorm.
Ist das Firestorm?
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das ist Firestorm, oder?
Ist das Firestorm?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist, muss Firestorm sein.
Ich hab Firestorm nie gespielt.
Firestorm, Alter.
Keck.
W.
Was, warum sind die Amis eigentlich, oder, was heißt die Amis?
Warum ist das im Englischen eigentlich so bescheuert, dass jeder Buchstabe schön kurz ist, aber W, W wird dann W ausgesprochen, so ewig lang.
Das, das verwirrt die Leute auch.
Kennt ihr, kennt ihr die Leute in CS?
Die, die dann, die dann statt, ähm, AWP.
Beziehungsweise AWP, sagen die, AWP, und sowas, das ist doch vollkommen logisch, weil das der einzige Buchstabe ist, der so kacke ist.
Das hätten die mal ordentlich nennen müssen.
Ich bin, ich bin dafür, die sollten das jetzt quasi retro, äh, aktiv umbenennen, dass, dass das jetzt in Zukunft nicht mal W ausgesprochen wird.
Kann sich doch keiner merken.
Im Spanischen auch.
Ja, haben diese auch nicht mal alle.
Ich mein, wir sind auch nicht besser.
Ich mein, Ypsilon.
Ja.
Ypsilon.
Wer hat sich das ausgesprochen?
Wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Das ist doch Usability Nightmare.
Deswegen sagen ja auch die, die cleveren Leute in CS, oder jetzt in Valorant ja auch, das ist eigentlich ganz, ganz lustig, die sagen ja AWP, weil die keinen Bock haben auf AWP.
Und ich, ich hab noch keinen gehört, der in irgendwelchen Valorant Streams die Sniper wirklich so, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Sniper in dem Game heißt.
Die nennen die alle wie die CS Sniper.
Die Griechen haben sich das ausgedacht.
Ja gut, die Griechen, die haben viele komische Dinger gemacht.
Die heißt Operator.
Okay.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Sagt keiner.
Ich hab sie übrigens immer noch nicht gespielt, aber ich gucke in letzter Zeit relativ viel Valorant Streams, weil ich das ganz interessant zum Zugucken finde.
Die meisten Leute, gerade bei Overwatch Streamern, sind ja voll am rumheulen.
So nach dem Motto, oh, Valorant, äh, Resident Sleeper, Overwatch POC, wo ich mir denke, Overwatch war seit zwei Jahren immer POC.
Das war jetzt so ein typischer Twitch-Satz, oder?
Overwatch war seit zwei Jahren nicht mal POC.
Das versteht außerhalb von Twitch nun wirklich keiner.
Ich frag mich eh, was mit Overwatch los ist.
Das ist komplett, komplett dead mittlerweile.
Ist komplett, komplett hinüber.
Wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt, Twitch.
Äh nein, ich will nicht meinen eigenen Stream aufmachen.
Nicht View-Button.
Ähm, guckt euch mal hier.
Eine Menge Valorant Gelaber.
Wo wir jetzt auch mittlerweile dazuzählen.
Ach, spielst du wieder?
Ich dachte, du hast dir das nochmal kurz angeguckt.
Ja, es gibt Ranks seit zwei Tagen oder drei Tagen oder so.
Und, wo bist du eingerankt worden, falls du noch da bist?
Ich rate mal, ich rate mal.
Ich sag, du bist Diamond, Diamond 1 oder 2.
Gold 1.
POC.
Na, mach dir nix draus.
Siegerl ist, glaub ich, Iron 3.
Oder sowas.
So, aber guckt euch mal an, wo ist hier Overwatch?
Ich mein, sogar fucking Fortnite ist mittlerweile nicht mal auf dem ersten Platz.
Dafür kommt jetzt Battle Royale-Cod-Geschichten.
Und so, und irgendwo, irgendwo, irgendwo hier kommt dann Overwatch jetzt so.
Wo ist es?
Immer noch kein Overwatch.
Hab ich's übersehen oder ist es einfach wirklich so weit unten?
Ich hab's bestimmt übersehen, oder?
Hier, Overwatch, da.
Ja, ich hab mich noch nicht an das neue Bild gewöhnt.
Der Held sieht auch richtig gut.
Gefällt mir überhaupt nicht.
Ey, ich mein, der Witz, okay, es ist, es ist, es ist guter Gesellschaft mit Apex Legends.
Die haben's auch verkackt.
Aber hier, das ist weit, weit, weit von dem vorbei.
Ich mein, ihr müsst euch mal angucken.
Overwatch hat ungefähr genauso viele Viewer wie Oldschool RuneScape.
Ja.
Das stimmt, die Drops machen viel Outs, aber die anderen Games oben haben keine Drops.
Es ist einfach irgendwie, Maples, was zum, was, was, was geht mit den Leuten ab, ey?
Jumpking.
Was kann ich, dass das überhaupt noch Leute spielen?
Und ich dachte, es wäre sowas wie Getting Over etwas, nach zwei Monaten, keinem mehr interessiert.
PoE, alles.
Tja, irgendwie sind die Blizzard-Spiele außer Hearthstone, Hearthstone ist, glaub ich, immer noch ganz gut dabei.
Ähm, und WoW.
Bisschen am Abscheißen, ne?
MapleStory ist ein Game für den Sibaro, aber eindeutig.
Ja, ja, ja.
Blizzard ist auch nicht mal das, was sie früher waren, nach Blackfire.
Schon lange nicht mehr.
Das letzte, was waren das letzte?
Na gut, also das letzte gute Game, was Blizzard rausgebracht hat, war schon Overwatch, kann man nix sagen.
Overwatch war nicht schlecht, die hatten bloß irgendwie keinen Plan, was sie mit dem Game machen sollten, hatte ich den Eindruck.
Sie hatten große Ambitionen und, und nen, nen Businessplan irgendwie.
Aber, keinen, keinen Content und, und, äh, Games.
Einen Gaming-Plan, so wirklich.
Ja, das ist A Real Rinax, das ist tatsächlich so, wenn da nicht ein großer streamt bei Overwatch hier, ist das, äh, äh, nicht nur ein paar große, das ist komplett dead.
Ich hatte es auch letztens gesehen, da war aber kein großer on, da hatte Overwatch, glaub ich, 1200 oder 1300 Zuschauer.
Oder, oder noch weniger, das war voller Marsch.
Das hab ich gar nicht gefunden, deswegen hab ich eben auch so weit runtergescrollt.
Wenn nicht ein paar große online sind, ist es vorbei.
Ja, bis der Rinax.
Ähm.
Ja, und das ist halt das, was ich sehe, was, äh, was sie halt bei Overwatch irgendwie verkackt haben.
Und, das letzte gute Game, was sie rausgebracht haben, ist meiner Meinung nach schon Overwatch, das war nicht schlecht, hatten halt keinen Plan, aber ansonsten, so wirklich Games, ich mein, die haben sogar Warcraft 3 wieder verkackt, ähm, so wirklich, das wirklich richtig, tja, das ist eigentlich ne gute Frage.
Manche sagen, dass CSGO dead ist, CSGO ist so groß wie selten zuvor, aber die Leute, für die ist alles dead.
Overwatch ist ja auch nicht dead im eigentlichen Sinne, äh, es ist bloß im Vergleich zu dem, wie es früher gewesen ist, komplett unbedeutend geworden.
Und wenn man sogar sieht, dass, ähm, dass jetzt sogar, äh, Sinatra, also der, der, der, der, was war er, bester, bester, bester Spieler der letzten Overwatch Season, Overwatch League Season.
Dass der jetzt gewechselt ist, ähm, zu ner anderen Organisation.
Ähm.
Avalorant spielt.
Sagt nicht sonderlich viel Gutes über Overwatch, ne.
Ja, Overwatch, die haben es ja bis heute nicht geschafft, ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter noch über Overwatch ablästern, die haben es ja bis heute nicht geschafft irgendwie, das Spiel halbwegs zu balancen.
Das ist auch schwer, ja.
Und das Blizzard ist ja bekannt dafür, dass Blizzard immer übertrieben nervt und dann übertrieben bufft und irgendwie nix, nix auf die Reihe kriegt.
Ist nicht so.
so dass andere spiele nicht auch das problem hätten aber overwatch haben sie
es irgendwie haben sie nie so richtig die kurve gekriegt der zweite teil wirkt
für mich auch irgendwie sehr halbherzig weiß ich interessiert sich überhaupt
irgendjemand für overwatch 2 die overwatch 2 mit glaube ich gar nicht
großartig was ändern kann ich mir kann ich mir nicht vorstellen und die haben
halt teilweise ultra lang gebraucht um was zu machen
ich war überlegt euch mal in der zeit wo hier auch wenn ich jetzt kein großer
ford hat wenn in der zeit wo ford night irgendwie 15 sachen rausgebracht hat mit
aktuellem bezug ja sei es irgendwie was sie tan aus patches und sonst was am
anfang übelst gehypt war hand die irgendwie ford hat 15 sachen rausgehauen
da hat es overwatch geschafft in der gleichen zeit mal einen comic zu
release noch nicht mal irgendwie irgendwie was zu machen die haben so 12
seiten comic released in der zeit wo ford hat 15 patches gekriegt hat so nach dem
motto das haben sie halt voll voll verkackt ja das gleiche auch dass du
dir teilweise manche sachen für ein halbes jahr geben musst die die absolut
unspaßig und bullshit mäßig waren ich hatte ja keinen bock mehr so
abschließend kein bock mehr wo das ganze nahkampf tankmeter am start war
somit brigitte stun und so was das war mir
zu doof wo ich mir gedacht habe ist es ist das jetzt das jetzt noch ein shooter
ist das irgendwie so ein mini brawler oder was ist das jeff kaplan ist der
unfinier wird das kann ich weiß ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so ganz
sicher inwieweit man da wem irgendwie was in die schuhe schieben kann
das ist das ist normalerweise bei ubisoft ja da hatten die nicht bei
ubisoft bei batista hast du den typ ich weiß nicht wie er heißt da der der fallout mensch der immer vor der
fallout mensch der immer vor der
kamera steht über denn hätten sie ja alle er hat der shop strahhlt nicht
alles alleine
was ist immer die beste idee ist aufderkommt die community zu hören das
problem was bild allgemein hat ist grundabhängig von heart jours das blinderd
Das, was Blizzard allgemein hat, Blizzard ist der Meinung, dass sie komplett die Weisheit mit Löffel gefressen haben und alle anderen sind Kack-Noobs, um nicht zu sagen Scheiß-Kack-Noobs.
Guckt euch mal an, wie lange hat Blizzard gebraucht, WoW Classic zu machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob WoW Classic jetzt immer noch Cues hat und sonst was. Es war auf jeden Fall erfolgreich, so viel kann man sagen.
Du wolltest doch Titanfall 2, das ist richtig.
Also, WoW Classic war auf jeden Fall erfolgreich.
Ob das jetzt jahrelanger Erfolg ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber WoW Classic ist definitiv ein Erfolg.
Wie lang und wie viel Überzeugungsarbeit hat es gebraucht, bis Blizzard sich mal dazu erbarmt hat, WoW Classic zu machen.
Und sie haben es ja auch nur gemacht irgendwann, weil wahrscheinlich ihnen die Leute zu sehr auf den Sack gingen.
Und sie haben hier selbst gar nicht so richtig...
... dran geglaubt. Das hast du am Anfang auch gesehen, mit Serverclustern und sonst was.
Und jetzt kam das ganze Raus und haben gesagt, hoch, fuck alle, die Leute spielen das ja.
Ich finde an WoW Classic sieht man ziemlich gut, dass Blizzard der Ansicht ist, sie haben wirklich die Weisheit komplett mit Löffeln gefressen, alles andere sind Scheiß-Kack-Noobs.
Es ist natürlich auch nicht immer die beste Idee, rein auf die Community zu hören.
Wenn man die Community in Reihenform erleben will, muss man sich mal die Kommentare unter ein paar Call of Duty Videos oder so auf YouTube angucken.
Ähm, das was die machen.
Was die meisten Leute da schreiben, ist komplett, ähm, hirnverbrannt, oder auch bei allen anderen Games.
Ähm, aber wo man, was man meiner Meinung nach hätte mehr machen müssen, oder was, was, äh, gerade Blizzard bei allen ihren Games mehr machen müsste, ist, sie müssten auf die Leute hören, die das professionell, beziehungsweise die da, die da mit ihr Geld verdienen.
Das haben die bei Fortnite gemacht, da kannst du nix sagen.
Ja, natürlich, ich sag's, klar hätte Blizzard mehr auf die Leute hören müssen.
Ähm, vor allem auf die, die Plan vom Game haben.
Ich hab Dota 2 nie gespielt.
Muss ich gleich mal ein Disclaimer sagen, ich bin ja auch nicht der, der MOBA-Bro.
Allerdings muss es ja bei, bei, spielt jemand Dota 2 von euch?
Allerdings muss es ja bei Dota 2 so sein, dass immer noch, ähm, was Balancing angeht und sonst was, das eines der besten Games ist, die es gibt.
Und unter anderem deswegen, weil, ähm, immer noch, wie heißt der denn, der Ober-Dota-Mann?
Er ist ja auch einer der Erfinder der ursprünglichen Sache mit am, mit am, am, am Status.
Was ist das für ne Video?
Icefrog, genau, Icefrog.
Was, was ist das? Warum ist das 19 Sekunden lang?
Ja, natürlich, Vater. Ich studiere immer.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Was zum Teufel soll das jetzt gewesen sein?
Und warum hat der Typ eine Rüstung an?
Warum hat der Typ eine Rüstung an und einen Shotgun an?
Die haben echt einen Dachschaden.
Der Typ ist auch geil, das ist doch der, den sie irgendwie fragen, auf welchem Platz
wird irgendwie ihre Fußballmannschaft landen und er sagt dann, ja, alle.
Jetzt hast du es, ab heute sind die deine Recommendations.
Scheiße.
Ich habe keinen View-Time.
Naja, gut, wo fangen wir an?
Also, WTF, ich rauche nicht, ich habe keine Erkältung, nichts, aber erstmal Husten.
Warum auch immer.
Mundschutz ist auf.
Rauchen nicht, aber kiffen, das auch nicht, aber ich bin dafür, dass sie den Scheiß legalisieren.
Ich verstehe den Sinn nicht.
Was?
Warum?
Normaler Schnaps, Zigaretten und sonst was legal ist, aber jemand, der ein Joint rauchen
will, ist irgendwie übelster Schwerverbrecher.
Das leuchtet mir nicht ganz ein.
Hast du Heuschnupfen?
Nö.
Auch nicht.
Ich war sechs Wochen nicht draußen, Alter.
Woher soll ich Heuschnupfen haben?
Ich habe seit sechs Wochen Homeoffice, ich war nicht einmal, nein, das stimmt nicht.
Jetzt habe ich es übertrieben, ja.
Ich war selten auf der Straße, ja.
Ich kann das eigentlich nirgendwo.
Ich kann das eigentlich nirgendwo herhaben.
Lüftest du?
Ja, das stimmt.
Mache ich.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich lüfte nicht.
Ich nehme den Lüftungsmodus von meiner Klimaanlage und der hat einen Pollenfilter.
Exzellenz.
So.
Also.
Make Windows look better.
Elegant look.
2020.
So.
Also.
Easy, Windows 10 Customization.
Warum soll man Windows look better lassen?
Hey, Max, denke dran.
Wenn ich nicht im Chat gucke, ihr müsst da add mein Name, also add Wubblus vorschreiben,
weil dann habe ich hier nämlich ein Tool laufen, das die Sachen mitloggt, die Anfragen nicht
kö personagem kommen, die übersehen, ansonsten sehe ich sie nicht.
Und wenn ich sie nicht sehe direkt, dann…
Tja, gut.
direkt dann bettel viel zum start kann man machen ich habe sogar ein battle
video auf ihr best bettel und sommer kein bettel viel video ich habe immer
bettel viel video offen gehabt das hier das also ja die frage wenn ich
bin idee wie nieder weiß ich ob das ob das so stimmt silberberg vier monate
hughes ab mega subs big brain subskription
da ich für den sap so was soll jetzt sagen wie die idee genau also hey max ich
möchte mir ein eigenes nass einen eigenen server bauen kannst du eine
seite empfehlen wo systeme vorgeschlagen werden bzw wie computer
base für gaming pc ja also es gibt für nass ist ich könnte
auf reddit ein paar empfehlen es gibt data order
und das ist ja auch so dass man sich da auch ein paar dinge anschauen kann
wobei das die extrem variante ist data order ist ein ganz gutes upgrade die
haben ganz gute server tests immer für den heimbereich
wie kannst du dir angucken und was haben wir dann sonst noch als reddit
homelab genau ja recht ja homelab ist auch ein ganz gutes self hostet ist auch
ein gutes reddit das stimmt das hat mir auch schon ein paar mal auf
hier ja ich weiß nicht ob du dann komplett
wie Traffic
auf Spotify ver";
reddit
e serves
Einfach Winnie, okay.
Excellent.
Beobachte mich, gib mir Aufmerksamkeit.
Bock. Hat funktioniert.
Du musst Channel Points
verwenden. Dann sehe ich das.
So, also.
Wo sind wir jetzt hier stehen geblieben?
Sniper vs. Tanks. Ich will mir vorher
ich will mir vorher diese Make Windows Look
Better angucken.
Weil die meisten Videos dieser Art sind
kompletter Blödsinn. Allerdings hat das gute
Bewertung.
Mach mal nice.
Ja, mach ich.
Wenn da ein Sub reinkommt, dann ist das nice.
Dann drücke ich auch nice.
Erstmal eine Runde Sellout starten.
Jetzt werden die Channel Points rausgehauen.
Werde mich mal mit dem
Thema befassen. Ja, das ist immer am besten, wenn man
sich das in Ruhe, wenn man da
jetzt keine große Eile hat, dass man morgen
irgendwas braucht, sich in Ruhe damit beschäftigt.
Ein paar Posts liest.
Und
sich erstmal überlegt, was man braucht.
Aber ich, also
wenn du jetzt keine allzu übertriebenen
Anforderungen an dein Nass hast, also
du kommst damit schon mit 300, 400
Euro gut aus. Ohne, ohne,
je nachdem, wie viele Platten du willst. Ohne Platten.
Ja, also ich
habe hier für 250 Euro so ein ganz billiges
Ding zusammengebaut und dafür war sogar noch eine
10G-Karte.
Alter, was ist denn heute los?
Eine 10G-Karte von Ebay drin.
Aber damit kann ich jetzt natürlich
auch keine großen Sprünge machen.
Wann kommt auf Git eigentlich das aktuelle Streamtool? Ich habe da
bis jetzt noch nichts geplant.
Das funktioniert für mich gerade mal gut
genug.